obi-wan kenobi's whole existence in the
star wars universe is tied up with the
fate of anakin skywalker and their
history is even longer and more
complicated than you might think this is
obi-wan's history with darth vader
explained
in the phantom menace obi-wan tells his
master qui-gon jinn that he senses
they've picked up another pathetic life
form referring to the young anakin
skywalker
this line demonstrates how from the very
beginning obi-wan didn't think they
needed extra baggage on their quest to
stop the trade federation's invasion of
naboo in fact obi-wan and anakin never
seem to gel in the phantom menace
as qui-gon waits to hear if the jedi
council will accept anakin as an
apprentice obi-wan even points out that
his master's defiance is preventing his
promotion to the council itself obi-wan
strictly adheres to the jedi code and
takes issue with qui-gon's constant
rebellion against it however when
qui-gon is killed by darth maul his
dying request is that obi-wan trained
the young anakin obi-wan himself briefly
takes on qui-gon's rebellious spirit
when he tells yoda he will train anakin
to fulfill this wish regardless of
whether the council approves obi-wan's
general fidelity to the jedi order and
its rules frequently contrasts with the
older anakin's perpetual rebellion
against them however the decision to go
against the council in the first place
is handed down by qui-gon who planted a
seed for the rift that would one day
tear the galaxy apart
from the start anakin skywalker is
depicted as a man of action while
obi-wan is a more careful and analytical
fighter a perfect example of this takes
place in attack of the clones when
anakin rushes in to fight count dooku
only to be knocked out by his enemies
force lightning meanwhile obi-wan
chooses to take a more defensive
approach and lasts longer in battle
because of it while anakin is seen as
something of a prodigy his reckless
actions often lead obi-wan to regard his
apprentice with exasperation as well as
admiration in the clone wars series
obi-wan frequently scolds anakin for
being too foolhardy while anakin often
calls out obi-wan for being too hesitant
we don't need the whole fleet i can do
this myself anakin slow down and do what
i tell you
it's more important to save lives than
destroy ships
anakin leaps into battle without
thinking about it and thanks to his
abilities always makes it out on the
other side on the other hand obi-wan
always tries to evaluate every situation
in order to come up with a proper plan
of course it's anakin's reckless need to
take action that eventually leads him to
the dark side no doubt the older obi-wan
would have wished that he had taken this
character flaw of anakin's far more
seriously
a key facet of the jedi code is that
force users should always avoid personal
attachments
anakin shows us why this principle is so
important because his love of padme
allows palpatine to manipulate him into
joining the dark side however anakin's
attachment to his relationships isn't
exclusive to padme it also includes
obi-wan himself obi-wan is a great
mentor
as wise as master yoda and
as powerful as master windu
attack of the clones demonstrates how
deep their relationship goes when anakin
sees obi-wan come under attack by
droidikas anakin had earlier pointed out
that obi-wan is the closest thing he has
to a father and he clearly wants to save
him from the droids but he's torn
between that desire and his duty to
protect padme thankfully padme actually
suggests trying to save obi-wan
themselves giving anakin the opportunity
to set out to rescue his master of
course it is this shared mission that
cements anakin and padme's love after
their rescue mission fails and the two
are sentenced to execution in a
gladiatorial arena they share a kiss
that later leads to marriage anakin's
inability to deny his personal
relationships is a flaw in his jedi
mindset that recurs throughout the
prequel era eventually leading to his
fall from grace
his affection for obi-wan is a central
issue in this dynamic making the history
that anakin padme and obi-wan share a
very dangerous thing
the phantom menace ends with obi-wan as
a full jedi knight and anakin as a
padawan a decade later attack of the
clones ends with anakin's marriage and
the beginning of the clone wars
following that the clone wars covers the
three-year gap between attack of the
clones and revenge of the sith given the
amount of ground the series covers it
has to be inferred that when the first
battle of geonosis takes place and the
war begins anakin is immediately
promoted to jedi knight as both he and
obi-wan are generals in the clone wars
from that time on obi-wan and anakin are
seen as colleagues on more or less the
same level and they are generally given
the same level of responsibility in most
situations
it's worth remembering however that not
only had anakin just been promoted but
he started his training considerably
later in life than most jedi if anakin
had bristled that obi-wan's instruction
before no doubt he really resents any
perceived seniority by this point
obi-wan however never seems to begrudge
the fact that anakin skips ahead to
become his equal
anakin skywalker was supposed to be
obi-wan student and you would expect a
master and student relationship to
continue in some shape or form even
after their formal training ends that
certainly seems to be the case with yoda
and his students as even count dooku
views his old master with respect
yet perhaps because of obi-wan and
anakin's closeness in age their equal
military ranks and anakin's exceptional
strength with the force they become more
like brothers than a student and a
teacher by the time anakin is a
full-fledged jedi he already seems to
think of himself as superior to his
master obi-wan is constantly advising
prudence while anakin almost always
thinks immediate action is the key to
victory this difference leads to
competition between the two as they seek
to prove that their approach is better
anakin is especially eager to prove that
he's stronger than obi-wan culminating
in their duel on mustafar in which
obi-wan insists anakin can't defeat him
the younger jedi acts rashly and is left
for dead as a result putting a final end
to their long and fateful sibling
rivalry
anakin tends to think that obi-wan is a
model of self-control to the point where
he mistakes obi-wan's adherence to the
austere jedi lifestyle for a lack of
emotion or passion yet we see in the
clone wars that obi-wan understands
anakin's longings more than skywalker
seem to realize he simply doesn't give
in to them take for instance obi-wan's
history with satin crees the ruler of
mandalore their relationship parallels
the dynamic between anakin and padme as
sateen is also a strong woman and a
political leader one clone war story arc
reveals that she and obi-wan once had a
romantic connection though it's never
clear if they acted on those feelings
however it's obvious obi-wan cares for
her and perhaps if he and anakin had
discussed their forbidden romances it
would have helped steer anakin away from
his eventual downfall despite what
anakin might think obi-wan also
questions the jedi order from time to
time this is first seen when he tells
yoda he will train anakin no matter what
the council decides but it is also made
apparent with his reaction to the jedi
order's vilification of ahsoka tano for
a crime he knows she did not commit
the real difference between those two
jedi is how they handle their issues
with the jedi order for all his power
anakin never learns to control his
emotions the way obi-wan does despite
obi-wan's pleas for his former padawan
to do so
in attack of the clones anakin angrily
complains to padme that obi-wan is
jealous and holding him back of course
this isn't the case at all obi-wan only
ever wants the best for anakin believing
that despite the boy's exceptional
skills with the force his padawan needed
to mature emotionally in order to become
a full jedi knight obviously obi-wan was
right several times in the clone wars
obi-wan tells anakin to play a situation
carefully only to watch as anakin rashly
springs into action sometimes it works
out but other times his brash choices
lead to high casualties or to obi-wan
having to rescue the young jedi
what anakin sees as obi-wan's jealousy
is actually his master's desire to guide
him to reach his full potential
eventually when obi-wan confronts darth
vader the former apprentice tells
obi-wan not to lecture him insisting
that he sees through the lies of the
jedi by extension he claims to see
through the supposed lies that obi-wan
had told him to keep him from fulfilling
his destiny
it's a tragic misinterpretation of their
entire relationship
in a new hope obi-wan says this of
anakin skywalker
he was the best star pilot in the galaxy
and a cunning warrior
more importantly though he adds
and he was a good friend
anakin's inability to identify and
control his emotions was a weakness that
palpatine easily exploited on the other
hand obi-wan may have felt a more
profound love for anakin than his
apprentice felt for him simply remaining
in control of those feelings obi-wan's
heart breaks when he watches the
security footage of anakin killing
younglings and on mustafar obi-wan
laments that he has failed his young
apprentice
obi-wan retreated to the life of a
hermit in order to hide from the empire
after the destruction of the jedi order
but you can't help but wonder whether he
also exiled himself as punishment for
preventing anakin from falling to the
dark side
when obi-wan appears in rebels a deep
sadness lingers over his bittersweet
victory against his longtime rival maul
in a new hope darth vader says that he
feels obi-wan's presence on the death
star so there can be no doubt that
obi-wan knew vader was there as well he
chooses to go alone on his mission in
part because the ever contemplative
obi-wan knows he will have to confront
his former apprentice
looking at their final showdown from
this point of view it is a reasonable
conclusion that obi-wan believes his
sacrifice to be a penance for failing
his old friend
after anakin becomes darth vader obi-wan
volunteers to watch over luke on
tatooine he didn't have to do this
however obi-wan could have left luke to
be raised by the lars family alone of
course he takes this mission in part out
of a desire to see a jedi re-emerge and
save the galaxy however another part of
him probably wants to protect the son of
a friend he once cared very deeply for
when obi-wan tells luke about his father
in a new hope he hides the true nature
of his relationship to darth vader
telling luke that vader betrayed and
murdered anakin skywalker
in return of the jedi obi-wan famously
claims that anakin ceased to exist once
he became vader and that what he told
luke was true from a certain point of
view it stands to reason that obi-wan
would have held on to his feelings for
his lost brother and that he probably
saw it as his duty to watch over and
protect his son
it's a well-known fact that obi-wan won
his victory over anakin on mustafar
because of his ability to claim the high
ground
this slight difference in elevation
allows obi-wan to slice off anakin's
limbs after he attempts to go for the
kill however this line applies to more
than just the physical difference
between the two jedi obi-wan has also
gained the moral high ground here and
it's hard to argue otherwise especially
considering that anakin has just
destroyed the jedi order he was sworn to
protect slaughtered the younglings and
attacked his own wife throughout the
prequels and the series obi-wan has a
firmer grasp of morality and duty than
anakin who often acts for selfish
reasons and while more stories in the
star wars galaxy may find obi-wan
struggling with the moral ambiguities of
life outside the order he will no doubt
always keep the high ground over his
former apprentice
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you